The next question regards the history of
fasting. Actually um was the time period
for the
observing
uh of a fast and abstaining from the
things which break the fast which you've
already mentioned always the same since
the beginning of time or for the
Muslims.
As far as the Muslims are concerned when
the first time it was mentioned in the
Quran in surah Bakar chapter 2 was 183
which I mentioned earlier that fasting
was fur at that time the Muslims used to
fast 3 days in a month.
Later on when the verse of the Quran was
revealed of surah bakar chapter number
two verse number 185 which I quoted the
second time that is the month in which
the Quran was revealed
and in it is guidance for the humankind
>> and in it are signs for guidance and
judgment right and wrong. So the Muslims
when they witness this month they should
fast. So then it became f for the Muslim
to fast the complete month of Ramna.
First it was only three days every month
then it became one full month only the
month of Ramadan. As far as the things
that break the fast are concerned. One
of the things that break the fast it is
sexual intercourse even with your wife.
So previously when this verse of surah
bakar chapter 2 verse number 185 was
revealed it was not mentioned in detail.
So the Muslims at that time they used to
abstain from sexual intercourse.
approaching their wives for the full
month of Ramadan even during the day and
night.
And it was very difficult for many of
the Muslims, many of the Sahabas. And
that reminds me of a quotation or
incident which is mentioned in one of
the commentaries of the Quran. If you
read the comment of the Quran volume
number two, page number 210,
it mentions there that may Allah be
pleased with him
once after speaking with the prophet
late in the night. He comes back home
and he has the urge to sleep with his
wife and he spends the time with his
wife and he has section into cost with
his wife. In the morning when he gets
up, he feels very bad. He's ashamed. He
immediately goes to the prophet and he
says that I asked pardon from Allah and
his messenger for what I've done and my
soul was attracted towards my wife and I
had a relationship with my wife in the
night. Is there any way that I can be
pardoned or is there any way that I can
escape? So the prophet said, "Is it true
that you actually did this?" He said yes
prophet. Prophet was shocked. How could
I um may Allah be pleased with him could
do a thing at that time it was privated.
He said yes Allah's messenger I did it
is anywhere I can be pardoned. So the
prophet said no one besides Allah can
give the command and alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah immediately after this the
verse of surah bakar chapter number two
verse number 187 was revealed. It says
that permitted to you
during the nights of the fast is
approaching your wives.
And then it says
that they are your garments and you are
the garments. That means your wives are
your garments and you are the garments
of your wife. And Allah says that we
know what you do secretly in the night
but Allah forgive you and from now
onwards you can approach your wives
during the nights of the fast and you
can eat and drink till the white thread
of dawn is differentiated from the black
thread. So when this verse was revealed
later on surakra 2 verse number 97 then
the rules were a bit more relaxed that
they could have sexual relationship with
their wife during the nights but during
the day they have to abstain.
Furthermore, as far as eating was
concerned, previously before Surah Bakar
chapter 2 verse number 187 was revealed,
the Muslims could eat and drink after
the sunsets. But the moment they sleep,
after that they can't eat. Then they can
eat only the next day after sunsets. So
there's the incident of one of the Sabas
may Allah be pleased with him. He worked
very hard and he was fasting.
And when it was time to break the fast,
he comes home and he tells his wife that
I want to have some food. So wife says
that there's no food in the house. I'll
just get it from outside. And she goes
out to get food. Now because he was
tired working the full day, by the time
the wife comes back, he goes to sleep.
When the wife comes back to the house,
she sees the husband has gone to sleep.
So now she says finish. Once he's gone
to sleep, he can't eat. So that night he
could not eat the next day he had to
fast and by evening the next day he
faints and the people go to the prophet
that this is what happened because once
you sleep you can't eat later on this
verse was which I said earlier surah
bakar chapter 2 verse number 27 which
says besides approaching your wives at
night you can eat and drink till the
white thread of dawn is differentiated
from the black thread. So then the rules
that we follow today that fasting means
that you have to abstain from food and
drink and nourishment as well as from
sexual intercourse
right from dawn until sunset and having
the intention that we have to be Allah
subhanaa tala. It's an act of worship.
So this is the history how we finally
got this